live right now oh my god we're live
I seem fun the Diary of Jen Kirkman
podcast episode 211 this episode is
sponsored by quip TOC space and our new
sponsor Rent the Runway oh my god you
can't even believe how excited I am now
listen if you're watching live this is
normally a podcast that I do from my
home and every once in a while I come to
the studio but I don't normally stream
it because this is what it is you're
watching someone do a podcast I think
you if you're a podcast person you're
probably hip to that that they can put
cameras in them now but if you're not
watching NASCAR or something exciting
it's going to look like this me sitting
me talking so I don't want any basis
boring of course it's boring it's a
[ __ ] podcast for boring people people
with people who listen to podcasts have
something wrong with them and I include
myself in this we need to be talked to
constantly soothed and just feel part of
something but we don't want to leave the
house so if you are not that person then
of course you won't like this and in
anything think it's a save your comments
I'll say him all for you she's a [ __ ]
she's a [ __ ] she doesn't like Bernie
she's ugly I got it
anyway oh my god how does that sound my
tour is officially over and then what
did I do I go start booking dates
already for next year now I have one
show left in Oklahoma City now again
this is more for the listener the
watcher well I do who cares what Jen I
am the only one freaking out about being
on camera you guys are fine it's me I
get it
oh okay I hope you're noticing all the
fabulous things here at feminist AF for
my necklace line on bauble bar comm oh
by the way I should mention there's a
35% off cyber monday sale happening
right now
get yourself a feminist s [ __ ] necklace
until your Nana it means and fun and
they have them in silver and all
different kinds of colors and there's
ones that say cat lady or single or
taken or over 40 or 30 ish there's one
that says I can't there's one that says
laundry day child free they're all silly
expressions that I think are fun to wear
around your neck
and some of them make a statement now my
whole this is not merch on the road this
is I literally have a necklace line
separate than me being a comedian I
don't bring them on the road with me
because they're custom made so I'm
trying to like segue into fun things
like designing so this is that they are
off sale December 31st and today Cyber
Monday 35% off with code cyber 35 if you
go to Jen Kirkman comm it's all in my
home page or go to my Twitter it's there
to bauble bar kombi a you ble bar calm
now I wasn't coughing before the mic
went on but I must have some morning
flim so anyway so here's the doom
business up top business up top business
up top she's a busy businesswoman she
needs to tell you things so I am I have
two more shows left this year I will be
in Oklahoma City this weekend Saturday
the the second at the Oklahoma
Contemporary Art Center I love that
place this is a special show for women
women only trans-inclusive of course I
know there's so many now I'm like the
old lady who is trying to do this like
progressive thing like the Wonder Woman
screenings because it's a show where the
money goes to organizations that support
women's health and especially in light
of all this harassment going on I
thought it would be fun not only to do
comedy that's really geared towards
women without risking I've had a lot of
dudes at my shows this year their arms
folded they're booing me I'm like I'm
just done a story about a guy who chased
me in a parking lot why does that offend
you so I thought it'd be nice and then
women who don't normally speak publicly
if they want to tell they're mean to
stories they can get on the mic and it's
just gonna be like just a special lady
affair for us to just feel safe and good
and um apology saw the great guys out
there who would have loved to be part of
it but you just come to any old show
anytime and you'll be part of it I'll
probably come to Oklahoma City again I
always go there so and there's gonna be
fun raffles I'll be raffling off
necklaces and books and all kinds of
things I'll be there selling merchandise
it'll be very hands-on and I will be
available before and after the show
selling merch it's like so communal so I
hope everyone goes to that Jen Kirkman
comm click tour dates and then my last
show is my Jen Kirkman dysfunctional
Christmas show which is December 7th at
the Hollywood improv
I have friends who've been in hallmark
movies I'm gonna interview them my
friend Kris and I are going to do a
sketch about Mary finding out she's
pregnant I'm gonna do stand-up people
are gonna tell dark stories I'm gonna
sing an Elvis song we're throwing candy
at you everyone bring an unwrapped book
children's book not don't bring uh
what's that David Foster Wallace book
that everyone pretends they read no nut
confederacy of dunces oh you are so
close oh this oh everyone screaming at
me David Foster Wallace book David
Foster David Foster Wallace book all I
can think of is his essay consider the
lobster what is that book I'm looking at
it right now oh my god oh my god
do you think this is why he killed
himself because people can't remember
the name of his books Infinite Jest
do not bring Infinite Jest to my
Christmas show unless you want to give a
copy to an adult but this is a
children's book Drive Barnes & Noble
does a book drive every year the books
will be going to and believe it's either
a school or library in downtown Los
Angeles that needs help and I'll be
doing raffles at that show and the money
from that will go to the Los Angeles
Food Bank
so with all that business out of the way
I'm gonna freak out of myself with this
throat um but that's what happens when
four months of touring comes to an end
is I start getting the phlegm and the
rasp so we're gonna take ma not gonna
take that much time off I'll be back in
New York City in January at Caroline's
comedy club
I have shows they're already on sale Jen
Kirkman com click tour dates and I'm
coming to Buffalo and Vermont and
Indiana and those aren't on sale yet but
you can save the dates you can go to my
website and see what the dates is yeah
if you join my email newsletter I mean
you'll know all this the minute it comes
out also on my website what
can I tell you my tour next year is
called the I don't give a [ __ ] tour now
I don't know what that means exactly but
I thought was snappy and also there's a
joke I have about not giving a [ __ ] but
it's not in a rude way okay this is the
worst I know it don't say kuzey it's
cozy
it doesn't fit anything except this kind
of bottle it says I am fun but I seem
fun I'm not fun that's okay
somebody requested that I live watch a
hallmark movie and and I did from my
sister's house last week God that
episodes long I almost crapped out
halfway through it was just like let me
just summarize the end but I stuck with
it and that comes out next week so I'm
just giving you plenty of warning oh I
forget the name in the movie because
maybe you could watch along and you
could tape it okay let me look that up
hallmark 2017 movie about an organizer
and hallmark 2017 movie about an
organizer and a widowed dad oh it came
right up Christmas in the air Christmas
in the air so everybody you have a week
to go on your TV I'm a hundred and go to
the Hallmark Channel and find a movie
scroll through cut Christmas in the air
record it and you can watch along with
me or you can just watch it in advance
so that you know what I'm talking about
or you can listen the episode and watch
it later but it's called Christmas in
the air it is about an organizer you
know like someone who organizes your
life and a busy widowed dad who's a
toymaker
you can't even deal with how good this
one is so I had asked you guys a night I
think all these episodes are gonna have
sort of a holiday theme I'm sorry if
that is upsetting to anybody but um you
know I don't know as to tell you what I
can tell you is that um what's our heart
out today Aaron ten
what huh so I can go to 1015 okay
perfect
I was reading about him because I was I
was a little bit of a sloth during sink
Thanksgiving Thanksgiving I had two
glasses of wine every day that was that
was big for me I don't normally drink
every day or even once a week I don't
drink
and two glasses is a lot
I don't film to the top I'm I use those
big ones and I kind of just do like a
quarter full so I can do this
but yeah so now my friends might be like
what are you talking about I've gone out
with you for dinner and we've gotten
blitzed you know five wines for me is
blitzed over like five hours and food
but that's once in a while that's once
every five months but this like the way
that people like I just have wine at
home I don't do that really it's not
worth the extra calories I do love the
little like just that warm little first
sip wine feeling but um I was just like
I'm gonna let myself enjoy and it was
totally fine um it's a good way to keep
warm but I actually oh I already talked
about this in the podcast because I
recorded one from home I actually kept
up with Pilates during the week that I
was home so that I think that's why I
didn't put on any extra poundage and it
lose anything but Thanksgiving it's not
the holiday to lose weight and I what
I'm talking about what was a [ __ ]
point of that I don't remember
because I wanted to talk about how
exciting my two glasses of wine were
with my mom like what I went off people
I partied is what I'm trying to say
sorry I keep doing that sound oh the
point is is the thing I'm about I'm
something's wrong with my brain god damn
it
the point is I'm about to read you a
thing about Princess Margaret and what
her daily life was like and you're
basically gonna kill yourself because
your life isn't this good like everyone
right now who's watching at their desk
you're gonna be like my life so
and it does compared to Princess
Margaret okay what is happening I'm
trying to take a selfie and my phone
just froze my is life so hard do you
think anyone's ever gonna be able to
tell me my camera just stopped working
my whole phone and this isn't the new
fancy one but it's the eight or whatever
the thing is how some weird oh I have a
lot of windows open oh my god
it has some weird glitches I can't
believe it's not letting me take a
selfie
I'm gonna reboot it
okay so I don't really know who Princess
Margaret is like where's she from who
she related to maybe just to get this
quick thing out I should let you know
because I don't even know Countess of
Snowdon where the [ __ ] that was the
younger daughter of King George the
sixth and Queen Elizabeth the Queen
Mother and the only sibling of Queen
Elizabeth the second Margaret spent much
of her childhood in the company of her
elder sister so wait how old okay she
was born in 1930 and died in 2002 there
you go okay so this was her life this is
an excerpt from I guess a book that's
coming out about her Princess Margaret
woke up at 9:00 a.m. and had breakfast
in bed followed by two hours in bed
listening to the radio reading the
newspapers and chain-smoking done her
life is better than all of ours and she
lived till 71 with the chain-smoking now
I don't know how if the last years of
her life were terrible if she had
emphysema but god that sounds amazing
okay so I don't it gets so much better
then she'd spend an hour in the bath and
after a lengthy primping session had a
vodka pick me up at precisely 12:30 p.m.
after that it was a four-course lunch I
don't really care about the I don't like
vodka oh so well precisely 11:00 a.m.
she gets in a bath
run by her lady's maid and then the
vodka picked me up at 12:30 then at 1:00
p.m. she joins the Queen Mother for a
four-course lunch served from an
informal silver dish I'm sure it's like
nicer than your nice stuff with half a
bottle of wine per person hey that was
like me over Thanksgiving two glasses my
two glasses didn't really make didn't
even take up half a bottle it was like a
quarter uh half on wine per person plus
fruit and half dozen varieties of cheese
oh my god that sounds so good and
doesn't say what she did after that like
what'd she do from 4:00 to 10:00 p.m. or
whatever but we don't know oh my god I
have the most exciting story but I don't
remember if I already told it on one of
the episodes so I'll just quickly say it
no you know what it doesn't matter it's
it's stupid anyway because I think it
might be I feel like the information I
met an actress who starred in a hallmark
movie that premiered this year a new one
about a lawyer who gives up her job as a
lawyer to become an ice sculptor
year-round and because she went back
home to save her family's to save the
town's
ice sculpting contest which no town has
ever but it cost ten thousand dollars
and I don't know it's one of the ones I
sort of skimmed through like it was on
the background I couldn't really
understand what was happening and this
woman came to one of my shows at the
improv my monthly show lab test which is
back in 2018 tickets are already on sale
I do it in a little intimate setting at
the Hollywood improv lab space cute
little cabaret about 40 50 seats
beautiful
believe me it's beautiful I've the best
cabarets so she came because her friend
is a listener of the podcast hi sorry I
forget your name and he's like this is
my friend and she was in that movie and
I was like oh my god and she is aware
that the movies are perhaps slightly
ridiculous um and she was really fun to
talk to so but that's her story and I'm
not gonna ruin it for you so anyway I
thought today I would
how long you been rolling there kiddo
okay I just want to make you know guys
I've got new advertisers today and I
want to do right by them I want to do
right by them
so before we get into the listener
emails I will tell you I am loving my
quip tooth brush now here's the deal
it's a subscription service and they
probably don't want me to put it that
way but I'm just before you get in your
car and start running to CVS let me
explain to you how it works okay so quip
queue UIP
the new company that's refreshing the
way people brush their teeth it's an
electric toothbrush it's a slim design
it's not one of those bulky bulk Orson's
and you don't have to like charge it on
a thing that's the best part that packs
premium vibration and timer features
into an ultra slim design so it kind of
like goes off and when you're supposed
to switch to a new section of your tooth
it's amazing and it doesn't have a big
price tag it's basically like if Apple
designed a toothbrush but without the
big price tag and it's half the cost of
the bulkier brushes whose names shall
not be mentioned you can even subscribe
to receive new brush heads on a dentist
recommended three month plan for just
five bucks including free shipping five
dollars people cheap but not cheap
quality it's backed by leading dentists
and was named as one of Time Magazine's
best inventions of 2016 they want a 2016
GQ grooming award and made it on oprah's
2017 New Year's Oh lists quip starts at
just $25 this is ridiculous they are
just throwing something at you for
basically for free and also I don't know
I mean I'm assuming people brush their
teeth but having good oral health
impacts your overall health even like
bad oral hygiene is linked to heart
disease so don't [ __ ] around with your
teeth people okay so anyway here's how
it goes you go to get quip calm GE T Q u
IP comm slash fun to get your first
refill pack for free with your quip
electric toothbrush that's a great
deal that's your first refill free at
get quick calm GE tqu IP comm slash fun
now I have been using this I took it on
the road with me oh it also has this
cool feature where you put the
toothbrush in it in its holder so that
the bristles aren't exposed but you can
a fit as fix is 68 a fix the holder to
your mirror in your bathroom now don't
keep it near your toilet you're not
supposed to keep your toothbrush on the
same side of the sink that's closer to
your toilet because when you flush
things fly out they didn't tell me to
mention that but I just I heard that
once a night I think about it all the
time so keep your thing affixed to the
mirror you can take it off and you can
put it back on I took it with me
traveling this week it was perfect and
it's like smaller than one long
toothbrush so it fits in my little
travel size bags so perfectly seriously
you don't need a big expensive to thrush
to get the oral care that you need get
the same refreshing clean with something
simpler that will give you the best
brushing experience you've ever had 75%
of us don't refresh our bristles or
visit the dentist on time that's why you
need equip it's just gonna automatically
come to you every three months and it
has its own toothpaste which gives
strengthens your teeth gives your mouth
a perfect clean feeling I can attest to
that so let's do it get quick calm it
will be love at first brush all right so
this is what I wanted to do is I had so
again this is gonna be you know kind of
a holiday
um can you jack up my headphones again
Aaron people unless my headphones are so
loud I start pushing my voice so this is
that's good
so okay I had asked people to write in
about die hard because I I'm just like I
don't see it as a Christmas movie I mean
yes it takes place at Christmas but I
think if we start we have to we have to
build a wall somewhere okay by the way
this is the beginning of the wall that
Trump is building to Mexico I don't know
why he started at the all things comedy
studio but its its star
and it'll be great advertising too so
yeah the walls being built when we have
to build a wall around we've got to
protect Christmas movies and not just
won't store to do Christmas well that
doesn't mean it's a Christmas movie and
and I'll announce a the perfect thing
I'm writing a script for the ABC network
that will be due right before Christmas
busy businesswoman I am and it's about a
girl who got dumped on Christmas and so
the first scene is Christmas and then we
jump and it's February and then we never
talk about Christmas again it's not a
Christmas sitcom it just begins at
Christmas so don't so I am the creator
of something just like die hard and I
what the [ __ ] this has not happened
sorry it's acid reflux folks or just a
little bit of maybe it's just a little
bit of a post nasal drip anyway people I
am not even including myself as an
author of a Christmas thing so just know
that I see both sides I see mine and
yours yours is wrong okay but let's take
emails from people who wanted to weigh
in ah
someone sent me a beautiful photo of she
was staying in an air B&B and the room
number was 911 and she wanted me to know
that I appreciate that thank you we got
our 911 reference oh oh and I'm so
excited because um I'm gonna be spending
Christmas in New York and one of the
things I'm gonna do one of my fans works
at the 9/11 Memorial Museum and she gave
me a free ticket it expires at the end
of the year so one of the things I'll be
doing is going to the 9/11 museum and
that's such a JKL Christmas and then
yeah I'm so excited so anyway um die
hard this is from Julia I don't consider
die hard a Christmas movie
I suspect more dudes might categorize
this as a Christmas movie yes an office
Christmas party but for me I don't think
if this one is a Christmas movie oh my
god isn't it on and randomly related
note and in case you wanted a 911
reference people it's all coming
together I to not read these in advance
I'm just open and I'm willy-nilly and
this woman sometimes the universe is
just really in sync you know I did go to
a meditation class last night where they
put crystals all over you so maybe
that's why I'm having such synchronicity
with 911 references today white woman
podcasting alert okay I don't really
think that's why but just in case
someone takes it out of context don't
I'm never reading the comments on this
guy's please stop sending me this I love
my fans my listeners do not send me
articles where people are talking [ __ ]
about me or podcasts I don't want to
know I I know that they're out there
every day I'm aware I am hated
especially for this louis c.k thing
which now I'm not hated for anything to
do with him except I talked about it
awkwardly once on my podcast years ago
and then took it down because I was
getting harassment not from him but from
people and then now there's this whole
thing that I'm involved in some cover up
it's insane I'm like I'm just a girl who
talked on a podcast that she didn't
think anyone listened to four years ago
and maybe mention that Louie was known
for jerking off in front of people but I
didn't know who they were but what what
the [ __ ] and I wasn't even offended or
saying he should have his career taken
away I was just saying it was actually a
very selfish story about myself
I was talking about how I kept getting
reviews in Melbourne Australia that my
show was dirty and it was so innocent I
talked about having a one-night stand
with a young boy boy he was 23 after my
divorce and how I did not like it and it
doesn't I won't even get into dirty
stuff I don't even say sex stuff I I say
like spent the night and they were like
this rowdy Bunji Bunji body Ron
she showed dirty and I was like dirty
I'm not dirty and I was like what about
likes time I'm like Louie who's like his
all act as dirty it's basically like a
confession to who he is and in real life
he's kind of dirty so I've heard
and so I've experienced him saying stuff
to me and that's what I said in my
podcast like when our women gonna be
allowed to be as dirty as they wanna and
um and then I I just kept talking and I
got printed by all these papers saying
it got twisted a game a telephone and I
was saying he touched me and then I took
it down there like she's being paid off
by him but for some reason they were mad
at me about it like not him like it was
so nonsensical and so certain outlets
are still talking about it to this day
so I'm sorry I'm sorry
the call is being pushed to tomorrow I'm
on a plane all day
hey everyone sorry I am on a plane most
of tomorrow I leave at sorry I just got
a business thing busy business woman I
leave at 7 a.m.
and land in New York City at 2:30 p.m.
and I had so as soon as you can because
I had some things in New York City
tomorrow and I'll need to reschedule
ASAP god damn it I have my home date oh
well that means I can go to Pilates
today I'm great okay anyway so anyway
what what the [ __ ] was I saying how did
that get into I don't know oh I said
white women podcast comments okay on a
randomly related note and in case you
wanted a 911 reference I can't believe
people advertise on this podcast I guess
it there's I guess that thing of like we
don't care about the content isn't like
a thing anymore maybe they do in case
you want to know 911 reference I believe
rentals of diehard skyrocketed after
9/11 because Americans wanted to see an
American kick some ass against
terrorists
I suspect this isn't news to you but I
couldn't resist a 911 reference actually
I didn't know that because I don't even
know that your diehard came out so who
knows 1988
what that long ago yeah well when did
moonlighting stop it was before that
well he was still in the air wow I
didn't know that he was in die hard in
the height of oh yeah it went on 89 so
Wow so he was like TV star movie star
but he did like a couple of bad movies
before die hard yes I didn't realize
that he I thought it was after he was
well established like oh wow this it
broke me - yeah I'm broken now because
people think it's a [ __ ] Christmas
movie if I may correct that email
they're not terrorists they're thieves
Oh in die hard
spoiler well maybe yeah we could just
say they wanted to see Americans kick
some ass against bad guys or girls with
any gal thieves and that know all dudes
mmm-hmm see the mist it was before the
women can be thieves - realization yeah
that that we have now we have an Asian
guy though okay yeah well there's always
an Asian and a black guy in those kind
of movies but they always I don't think
they think of now that now they realize
they can put women in a hot leather
outfit and she can be a thief - yeah so
congrats ladies you've really come a
long way
well here's someone else saying hey Jen
so happy you mentioned how bad that Paul
McCartney Christmas song is it literally
makes me walk out of whatever store I'm
in when it plays me - I would play it
for you right now but I'm afraid I'll
get sued
die hard it's one of my favorite with a
you where's this guy from movies and in
recent years it seems to have become
cool to say that any film that happens
to take place at Christmas is a
Christmas film thank you I don't think
it is for me a Christmas film needs to
be Christmas themed and have a high
cheese factor it needs to be sentimental
and comforting well again some people
are comforted by ass-kicking in the UK
we have a channel called Christmas
24 oh I know I know about Christmas 24 I
have played the UK you know twice
actually I was there what the hell is
happening I was there when was it -
November's ago
- November's ago and it was right after
Thanksgiving knows right before
Thanksgiving and all the Christmas stuff
was already up and I was staying in some
kind of a flat they put me up in and I
watched I had Christmas 24 on in the
background or whatever it's called and
you know it was not my culture so I
couldn't miss if American and British
culture so different but you know what I
mean it wasn't like the usual cast of
characters like your Candace Cameron
Bure or Lacey Chabert your alicia witt
so I was like okay I mean I'm glad it's
on but I don't know these people but oh
this is my spine I'd sinus acting up I
forgot I have a thing in the back of my
nose that I could get surgery on because
it's near your brain they stick a
balloon up and they drain I've had this
blockage probably for ten years it's
like sometimes you'll get a cold or an
infection and this blockage never leaves
it has to be drained and there's a tiny
hole in it and it drips post-nasal drip
down and then sometimes it doesn't it's
sort of like an on-again-off-again
things sort of like Sam and Diane on
Cheers and so my doctor my my
otolaryngologist or whatever what the
[ __ ]
anyway
and for the future ones
okay so sorry I it's bit Monday morning
at 9 a.m. everyone's back this is what I
[ __ ] hate about vacation I work a
little bit every day so that I never get
overwhelmed and I send on a bunch of
emails over Thanksgiving because that's
how I do if you're in my life in any
capacity if you're an agent a manager
someone who helps me out with stuff I'm
like you don't need to respond now I
know it's Thanksgiving I'm sitting on
the couch finally looking at my to-do
list
bump up up up up up up up up and then
all the answers are coming in now Monday
at 9 a.m. and I'm like Jesus
so anyway die hard okay yeah I I get it
if I was to accept die hard as a
Christmas film I'd have to then say
gremlins is my favorite Christmas film
it's Christmas themed has a Santa
presence and a nice cheesy sentiment at
the end yeah it has little evil
creatures but then they could pass as
elves in summary no to die hard being a
Christmas film gremlins I forgot was
that Christmas but they don't learn
anything at the end does something to
with Christmas so that's not a Christmas
film either Christmas favorites die hard
my favorite Christmas movie home alone I
don't like that one
I'm 31 so I was the perfect age when it
came out it's funny and charming and the
music is gorgeous and everyone is
amazing in it I just missed my window of
having a crush on Macaulay Culkin I
think wait how long does he how old
yeah he's 37 okay so I'm he's six years
younger than me so when he was in my
girl remember that movie where he died
of a bee sting spoiler alert and her dad
was what's-his-name from CERN dan
Aykroyd his best friend was a girl whose
dad was an undertaker and they lived in
you know a house that had the funeral
parlor underneath and Macaulay Culkin
was her best friend and I knew who went
watching it when did my girl come out
what year did my girl come out I bet it
was 88 yeah I think it was 90 because he
reminded me 91 so I knew in 91 and I was
six
tene in 91 I was like and he was 10 so I
was like if I were 10 that's the little
boy I have a crush on because I had a
crush on a boy my age who looked just
like that um and was as sweet as him and
and we end up dating for a little bit
and then now he's married it didn't
happen in that order it wasn't like we
dated then he's like I gotta get married
it was like I moved on and moved to New
York anyway so I always miss my macaulay
culkin window but I always feel like I
would have had a crush on him if we were
the same age
growing up in culture mine was more my
heroin addict of choice was River
Phoenix that was my crush and and I hear
Macaulay Culkin is doing better which is
good to hear because I root for him
anyone with a fucked-up childhood whose
dad took all their money I root for you
I'm rooting for you I hope he is okay
but I I just don't care about home alone
I think because I look at it and I see
the tragedy of a child being I'm talking
about the real person not this character
the tragedy of a child being in the
business and having shitty parents so I
can't look at that movie and I'm sorry
sorry if I'm ruining it for everyone
else but all I see is someone who's
already on track to have addiction on
track to have addiction problems and I
just feel sad for him so whatever she
says the music is gorgeous and everyone
is amazing in it and as I learned on a
recent live episode Donald Trump was in
home alone too so I ain't gonna be
watching that anytime soon
she said die hard it's not a Christmas
movie three for three
in the traditional sense it's not about
the holiday or the spirit there's no
Santa or busy businesswoman nobody
learns that's a homework Christmas movie
nobody learns about giving her family or
any of that it just doesn't have any of
the many qualities that make up a
Christmas movie and I feel like you can
watch it at any time of year
whereas I wouldn't watch a Christmas
story in June I just was thinking of
that I heard a Christmas song this
morning I went to get my hair blown out
and I was like I'm in the mood for this
now if I heard it in July it's like for
some
yeah it feels wrong now my sister and I
sometimes have watched elf in July for
no reason but my least favorite
Christmas movie elf I don't get it I try
to but I don't what what what I think
you're too young because it is a nod to
the animatronic rudolph
which is so ingrained in my DNA that if
you weren't a fan of rank and ambass
Rodolphe growing up I don't know if you
will get elf but I'm I need a moment
because it's just it's wrong you're
wrong um my least favorite Christmas
song wonderful Christmas time by Paul
McCartney oh I want to die when I hear
that song it's infuriating and awful and
obnoxious and it gets stuck in my head
it's stuck in my head right now
Christmas song that makes me cry I know
it's cliche but the Christmas shoes the
[ __ ] song is that the Christmas shoes
I'm gonna look that up the Christmas
shoes song isn't new it's got to be new
no it was almost Christmas time there I
stood in another line trying to buy that
laugh to get last gift er - not really
in the Christmas mood standing right in
front of me was a little boy waiting
anxiously pacing around like little boys
do and in his hands he held a pair of
shoes his clothes were worn and old he
was dirty from head to toe and when it
came his time to pay I couldn't believe
what I heard him say sir I want to buy
these shoes for my mama please it's
Christmas even these shoes are just her
size that doesn't rhyme could you hurry
sir daddy says there's not much time you
see she's been sick for a while and I
know these shoes would make her smile
and I want her to look beautiful if mama
meets Jesus tonight what the [ __ ] he
counted pennies for what seemed like
years then the cashier said son there's
not enough here what if she did meet
Jesus and he's like so not into shoes
he's like okay great she's like I wore
these feet of Jesus um then he turned
and looked at me he said mama made
Christmas good at our house though most
of the years she just did without tell
me sir what am I going to do somehow
I've got to buy her these Christmas
shoes so I laid so I'll never forget the
look on his face when he said mom is
gonna look so great sir I want to buy
these shoes for my mama please we get it
he paid
for them how much could you hurry sir
daddy says there's not much time and I
know these okay it just goes over and
over and over wait it doesn't say if the
person ever bought him the shoes it just
keeps going over and over my dad says
there's no time to student when I'm
wearing for Jesus oh it's a Christian
gospel song released in 2000 okay so
that's why I don't know it because so I
feel like Christians won't mind if I
play a little bit of it I thought it was
like a Toby Keith song or something
anything where someone's dying and the
little kid is being so sweet about it
and like almost an adult like they're
able to hit how long did this okay all
right and I'm not making fun of
Christianity you you all know my stance
I love all religions and I think it's
great those shoe display and the music
video is so random it looks really bad
and they look like a size four no I
can't with this guy's little boy am I
gonna get in trouble with YouTube's
copyright Oh Aaron's nodding but I made
up the lyrics yeah no no we should be
okay that was parody everybody I'm not
making fun of it but that guy's voice is
too much for me listen sometimes is he's
like a dime-store Bob Seger no that's
great dime-store Bob Seger so is Bob
Sieck no I'm just kidding Hollywood
nights do you know that that song is not
on iTunes or at least it wasn't years
ago when I was I was desperate for a
Hollywood nights fix and I downloaded it
five times before I realized I kept
downloading covers like not even covers
done by like Aerosmith but like
literally someone doing karaoke I mean
that song is so good okay what minute
are we at oh my god I got to talk about
as for mattress you guys so I'm I'm away
for a week right and I'm staying uh oh
no we're not talk doing Casper mattress
today Oh delete that ignore that rewind
rewind okay I need to talk about I am a
member of Rent the Runway okay
it's Rent the Runway comm and I have
it's a place where you can rent like
really expensive clothes or just really
nice clothes and some of them aren't
expensive but it's it's a lot of it of
stuff that maybe you wouldn't you know
afford in your own life like I'm gonna
buy this $700 silk blouse and you rent
them for a certain period of time I'm an
unlimited member so I pay a certain fee
every month and then I can it's almost
like the old Netflix where you can keep
the clothes as long as you want and you
have three items and you send them back
and so I use it all the time I've been
using it for years I use it because they
go on the road a lot and I'm I was
taking pictures with the fans hi
everybody
and I want to look like I'm wearing a
different outfit every time but there's
only so many clothes I can buy if I'm
doing eight shows a month I can keep
buying all the [ __ ] and so I love it I
rent different things and I've even
fallen in love with some things and I
ended up buying them that you do have an
option to buy so I couldn't believe when
Rent the Runway wanted to advertise on I
seem fun I am seriously I've been using
this product for years I'm obsessed with
it it's the greatest thing that's ever
happened to me and I've even gone to
their store in New York City now that's
I have to read like the official copy so
it's perfect for like you just
especially if people want to simplify
their closets like I don't want this
stuff and you're like oh what am I gonna
wear
this helps so I am introducing Wrentham
runways unlimited membership Jen Kirkman
is one you get unlimited access to a
constantly rotating dream closet full of
designer styles that you can keep as
long as you want and swap anytime and I
gotta tell you there are so many styles
to pick from you you basically have to
keep like a like you know you have to
keep a section of things you like
because it's not like there's just five
things on the website there's a billion
and it's like designers like Diane von
Furstenberg in theory and Tory Burch
there's jewelry there's pocketbooks pop
boxes purses you could have like a
super-expensive Kate Spade person be
like oh yeah I bought it it's the only
place you can rent styles from over 450
top designer brands such as Vince Theory
Tory Burch Derek Lam Opening Ceremony
Marnie DVF and more and seriously
there's even beautiful get like Marchesa
gowns on there that you can get for
holiday things oh my god is perfect it's
not only cheaper than buying it's faster
and easier to free shipping and
dry-cleaning on every piece I gotta
admit one time I went to a party last
year I was I had rented like this
beautiful fake fur coat I gotta admit I
was I was in a mood I was in a I felt
like I was a really bad actress in that
movie home again that I did and I had a
really tough night of filming because I
was like I suck at this and then I had
to go to a birthday party the next night
and I was still feeling that like weird
shame of like I think I sucked and
everyone was like oh my god she blows
and I bummed a cigarette of someone
which is something I shouldn't have done
and I was wearing my rent the runway
fake fur coat and like this smells like
smoke but you send it back and they
clean it maybe they didn't want me to
say that maybe or maybe they want me to
keep it real go to rent the runway calm
or download the app you go to download
the app that's what I have and choose
from tops dresses handbags many more for
any occasion if you fall in love with
any style you can buy it at an exclusive
discount and keep it forever
70% of unlimited members actually report
spending less money on clothes after
joining this is a million percent true I
literally never shop for clothes anymore
I have my basics and then I add the Rent
the Runway to when I have a special
occasion or I go on the road absolutely
so join six million members who make
Rent the Runway the largest clothing
rental company in the world now go to
Rent the Runway comm and download the
app to get 25 percent off of your first
month's unlimited membership with promo
code fun at checkout Rent the Runway
dot-com promo code fun now renting
provides a great way to get a ton of
variety without committing oh we have
this select four pieces at a time keep
them as long as you want and when you're
ready for something new
swap any of your pieces for fresh style
if you fall in love with a style you can
buy an exclusive discount and keep it
forever I think I just said the same
thing twice oh my god and I've also gone
to the flagship store in New York City
which is so fun but it's changed my life
people and uh and they come in these
cool bags and you literally don't do you
put it back in the bag they already have
the shipping label for you you just put
you have to go print a shipping label
it's so easy so thank you friend the
runway for being part of I seem fun and
if you guys I know you guys like my
clothing and your I was like where'd you
get that it's most of the time I'm gonna
say Rent the Runway
so okie dokie let's keep on this I know
this is probably like the most boring
episode ever
I don't care let's do some things so we
get the die hard thing I'm gonna have
people talk about their favorite things
in a minute die hard is not a Christmas
movie I saw it in the theater when I was
16 and that was July so for nearly 30
years I've associated it with summer
thank you and 90% of the times I've seen
it since I haven't been anywhere near
Christmas
despite its setting and let it snow
playing over the closing credits and
that's just one of those I know exactly
what they're doing they let it snow that
used to do it in moonlighting I call it
killing two oldies they put an oldies
song on while something [ __ ] up is
happening so it'll be like you know like
boom boom Shh boom the night we met I
knew I needed you so and someone's like
strangling someone and putting him in a
body bag and you're like that's weird
song to play during that and I bet let
it snow is like all the bad guys are
dead glad it's not it's I get it I get
it that that's not a Christmas movie
that's ironic music choice it's like
when they play scenes of Vietnam and
then Louis Armstrong's what a wonderful
world is over it's like Oh gets yeah I
just don't associate it with Christmas
and there are no Christmas specials or
movies I enjoy watching before November
or after December 25th so it is
therefore not a Christmas movie besides
there been five diehards and only the
first two took place at Christmas which
means the franchise exists outside of
Christmas yippee ki-yay
I thought neither one was at Christmas I
didn't even know there were five
diehards too many
Aaron agrees there's five he can confirm
only one and three are good you mean
die hard one and die hard three yeah
two's oh but it's not as good four and
five
is he getting too old to be doing it no
they're just ridiculous
he like hops on a jet in four well
that's insane yeah you mean on the way
hops on to a jet and how high does a jet
go I saw a picture the other day of two
Daredevils playing like tennis on a
plane that was flying above something
but was those old fashioned like Wright
brothers planes and I don't know but it
still was crazy to me that they were
standing on the wings of it but it can
be done but not a jet no I mean
literally wouldn't be able to hold on no
you would be thrown off even if it was
just taxiing down the runway how do you
even hold on I'm so angry for you I'm
angry for everybody
favorite movies okay so now I'm just
getting into the favorite things I asked
people to email me their favorite things
before we do let me just tell you that
one of my favorite things is going to
therapy you in therapy Aaron no well
that's why your life is spiraling Aaron
just said before the podcast because my
life is spiraling I go Aaron you should
go to there because I can't
I'm just getting hidden say any of that
but some of you some of you and I've
been saying this I've been seeing guys
you get your Beachbody for summer and
you get your ice you get your mental
health head for winter right let the
body go time to eat put on a sweater
you've got to prepare your mind for
going home
I went home I'm in therapy and I still
sobbed in bed for two hours because I
just can't deal with Trump supporters so
here's the deal now that's odd I didn't
make a very good pitch for therapy
but what was cool about it was I was
able to feel my feelings without it
being it wasn't like a dramatic stomping
off it was just like I need to go away
feel my feelings these are feelings
these are not facts and I can still make
a decision to love the people in my life
it's not this out of control whatever so
I'm telling you it really helps cuz you
know you don't do therapy so feelings go
away you do them so you learn how to do
so anyway I bet some of you just had a
thanksgiving and you're like oh my god I
can't I can't
and so maybe you can if you if you do
some therapy before Christmas so let's
do it I love talk space talk space.com
slash Jen je and it is the online
therapy company for as little as thirty
two dollars a week you pick an
experienced licensed therapist that
matches with you you get to pick them
and I'll just throw some guy at you and
be like you have to deal with Michael
and you're like I hate him that's not
how it works and each therapist has at
least a master's degree has completed
3000 hours of supervised work so these
are the real deal and people that use
talk space have said they love it
because it's private
you don't have to drive anywhere it's
like 80 percent cheaper than a therapy
session in person and you don't need
insurance for it and you won't need
insurance for it cuz it's very
inexpensive so go to talk space.com
slash Jen and to show your support for
this podcast use code Jen je n to get
$30 off of your first month okay we need
to take better care of ourselves this
time of year so that we can take care of
others put the oxygen mask on yourself
before you put it on the kid that is
what therapy is take care of yourself
talk space therapists are fully licensed
they go through a rigorous screening
process and you pick your therapist
based on your preferences you can text
audio video message or even do a live
video chat again talk space.com slash
Jen do it thirty bucks off alright get
back to people talking about they
favorite things favorite Christmas movie
It's a Wonderful Life it's trite I know
but I love every bit of it I wish I had
a million dollars hot dog I know last
year my ex and I went to see It's a
Wonderful Life at a movie theater in Los
Angeles and we got all dressed up and
he'd never seen it before and I always
loved experience it was someone who'd
never seen it and I'm just like tears
sobbing and then my relationship was
over two days later no I had nothing to
do with It's a Wonderful Life but it was
a wonderful Christmas even a even better
Christmas and so imagine my shock so I
don't know if I can handle watching It's
a Wonderful Life this year I feel in a
really good place and you know I don't
think that this year I'm going to be
like oh I'm sad I miss him
I think I might just be like it is noted
that a year has gone by I've done a lot
of work myself there's been a lot of
tears and a lot of just figuring things
out and but I don't know if I can
revisit that movie but I probably can
because it's meant something to me my
whole life as you know I get very
frustrated that you know George Bailey I
actually talked to dr. Drew about this
affair about the movie and he was saying
that he I said no it don't shift to
compromise in a relationship like George
Bailey wanted to travel the world and he
never got to because he had to save his
father's business then his brother went
away and then he had the kids and then
he lost the money somehow and and that's
why he wanted to kill himself because he
was like I just ruined everything and be
better if I was never born and then they
take him through and they're like no
you've impacted so many people it's
starting with this you saved a life but
and so we kind of get away from the fact
that he wanted to be an explorer now I
get you don't always get to do what you
want when you're a kid but on their
honeymoon they were gonna go away and
they're like we've got money we're gonna
go to the Caribbean and whatever and
then something happen so at the end of
the movie everyone donates money to him
and his warrant for arrest is ripped up
and somebody makes a toast to George
Bailey the richest man in town now I
know they mean rich with family and love
but I also think he got like a lot of
money and I'm wondering like did him his
wife go on a trip like I just want
George Bailey to get on a goddamn plane
once in his life and see something I
think he deserves that because he gave
Mary everything she wanted she lives in
that crappy old house she got the kids
the loving husband that she wanted to
live in that tent she got everything she
does he get anything I wonder and dr.
Drew's point of view was like he learned
that he loved his life and I go I got it
but aren't we allowed to have one thing
from our dreams you know growing up so I
really would love to make just like a
10-minute like director's cut where they
see him traveling and he's like cool I'm
gonna have a travel budget every year
and try to go somewhere and you know
what I actually don't want to be an
explorer it seems like a pain in the ass
turns out I'm just a guy who wants to
travel
and I had judgments about this being a
filthy fleabag small town but actually
loved it now and I feel like it's the
biggest place in the world but also I
wasn't wrong I love to travel and maybe
my son will be an explorer or my
daughter like that's to me the perfect
like if they just could do that during
the credits so I could feel better about
that because it just got favorite
Christmas song oh holy night I have been
I have so many people in my life who
told me that that's their favorite
Christmas song I don't get it it's I
don't know it's to me it's like boring I
love Silent Night that don't even play
that for me I start crying oh holy night
feeling boring to me but what it teaches
him Lee's favorite Christmas song
three-way tie between I want a
hippopotamus for Christmas what the [ __ ]
is that grandma got run over by a
reindeer and hey Santa I don't know that
two of those I can't understand my
favorite things please don't say my name
my favorite Christmas movie is home
alone ah my favorite Christmas song is
rockin around the Christmas tree right
Brenda Leigh that's a good one oh by the
way if you guys want to mess if anyone
out there is related to anyone who's
like they don't say Merry Christmas
anymore Google happy holidays and a lot
and put 19 40 50 Bing Crosby all of
those people had albums called happy
holidays happy holidays I think it was
Brendan Lee as well everything was happy
holidays there's a movie called Holiday
Inn although they sing white Christmas
in it but so just in case anyone your
family wants to pull that I wish it was
the old time when we could say Merry
Christmas people have always been saying
both because even Christians it's two
holidays for us it's it's New Years it's
a holiday season Thanksgiving Christmas
news let's get over it okay I really
can't get into Christmas songs performed
by pop singers me neither oh my come one
time somebody in my ex-husband's family
found out I loved Christmas music but I
was like whoa I'm talking Frank Sinatra
Nat King Cole the Phil Spector Christmas
album Leigh
redbone like that and they've got me
like a Mariah Carey and everything go no
I cannot I cannot I can even do Wham's
last Christmas but I don't even think of
that as a Christmas song it's like die
hard to me like you can listen to that
any time I just don't feel like
listening to it really any time but hi
Jen I hope it's not too late here's my
list favorite Christmas movie Love
Actually okay
Aaron's shaking a said have you seen
this movie yes have you seen it all the
way through yes I have a night I'm not a
movie stop because I've seen Devil Wears
Prada forty times I know it's not some
you know great film well it's actually
pretty good movie um I've been on a
plane and I'm like you know what I want
to zone out and as my friend Chris
Manjula says I'll look at some famous
good-looking faces yeah sure and and I
get bored or confused or something
happens and I'm like whatever I cannot
get past the first half-hour and I have
a crush on Hugh Grant I can't get
through it yeah there's some huge
bummers in that movie is one of them his
like super young assistant and he's some
kind of senator person in Parliament
Prime Minister is that weird yeah or
she's not that much younger or I don't
remember what happened
she seems younger yes and I don't know
what else what's another bummer in that
movie Alan Rickman almost cheats on
Helen
the great Emma Thompson okay the great
uh-huh well that was me trying to figure
out who she was and then came up I know
you're upset with almost cheats on but I
would say this is the point of the film
though isn't it messy love relationships
no yeah but as a great Christmas movie
where everything kind of works out oh
god it does everything work out at the
end no she's like she knows about it and
she's mad at no see that's my kind of
Christmas movie this yeah I mean I guess
that is actually that is life actually
although I think you also the the friend
the best friend it's always cited as one
of the most romantic scenes ever or it's
like the friend of the newly married
couple who proposes his love to the girl
with the card
you know oh is that what that's from
yeah yeah it's the guy from walking dead
okay holding the cards yeah that's
that's wrong and you think that scene is
not romantic no that's terrible
you think it's stalkerish are you're
saying so they'd broken up and she was
like I want nothing to do know they
never dated he was just the best friend
of the groom basically oh so he just
without even a kiss yep without even
maybe they're not compatible I have a
crush on you I'm proposing with cards
did she say yes no just like flattered
ah but it's like and it's just her
secret between him and her and doesn't
know it's just like well now we can
never hang out Wow do you know that you
are making this movie so appealing to me
right now because I want to see a bunch
of things not work out like that is
awesome that is so funny yeah you can't
hang out with that person ever again no
and it's not even that no you could hang
out with a friend this is I have a crush
on you you're like oh I don't maybe it's
weird for a while and they meet someone
who's fine but that yeah no no oh my god
that's so [ __ ] funny oh we have to go
um what was I gonna say Love Actually
my favorite movie oh you know what movie
I love it's so because I love that it
doesn't work out in the end even though
I think it should is my best friend's
wedding like her behavior Julia Roberts
fever is so bad I can't remember what
she does she sends like an email that's
fake she tries to break up her best
friend and his the girl and the girl
represents every kind of sort of sexist
but also kind of true like if a guy you
like that you have everything in common
with and everything's awesome
they always sort of seem to like this
dumb person and you're like what about
me and it's like why I don't like the
movie cuz I'm like why isn't he wired to
like his best friend but then she's so
like unforgivable in it that you kind of
go it's actually a perfect movie she's
so unforgivable that you're like I guess
it makes sense that he doesn't go with
her but she's so human that you're like
oh I don't want her to have a bad life
and so she just sort of her gay best
friend Rupert Everett shows up at the
reception and he dances with her and I'm
because she doesn't get what she wants
and just move on and you know it's
beautiful I know I love that movie it's
not a Christmas movie I also have a
weird thing about Julia Roberts that I
watch anything she does and I've heard
she's not a nice person I don't care I
literally don't care she could be as
mean as she wants to me okay well you
know what I'm I'm I'm my mom ah
Christmas song that makes me cry have
yourself a merry little Christmas shut
it down I can't listen to that song
either I mean my favorite Christmas
movie is a guy who's not a nice person
Chevy Chase and holiday vacation it's
called holiday vacation there's a war on
Christmas I don't know no Christmas
vacation
oh yeah I know that you know I don't
know me like comedy holiday movies but
that when I'm okay with Bad Santa like I
get it I don't think people are stupid
if they like it but I can't watch it elf
to me is funny but I think it's I still
cry that I cry every time I don't know
why anything oh God anything where a
bunch of people come together and they
believe and then something magical
happens you got me in it's New York and
we just love New York
we just love New York we that's not
refer to myself as we know okay there is
thousands of emails and I really think
if you guys will allow it the rest of
the month well it's not December yet but
except for next week where I'm narrating
a movie I think the rest of December is
going to be your listener emails of
favorite things and if diehard is a
Christmas movie because I really I
really think oh god yes Eastern Time I
am landing 2:30 p.m. Eastern Time sorry
so anyway my friends I will tell you
this I lost my train of thought I will
tell you this I have to end up before
you go if you're really watching this
bauble bar kombi au b lr BAU b le
bar.com
35% off cyber 35 cyber monday my
necklace collection it goes away
it goes away in December so just do it
just [ __ ] do it get someone a gift
don't be such a Grinch all right
and with that until next week have fun
okay sorry it really is helped me I kept
going